Hello
everybody!
Hello, hello!
It has been a very, very long time since we last streamed Marvel Rivals.
An entire three whole days.
Oh my god.
We might as well be dead already.
It felt so long.
I can't believe we get to be back with Marvel Rivals.
What a long break we had from that game.
Please.
It felt like everybody got families and moved on, but I never truly moved on from Marvel Rivals.
Every day, every minute, I closed my eyes and I was like, I wonder what he's doing right now.
I wonder what Mr. Rivals is doing right now.
So, I know some people were like, Toki, I thought you said you're returning back to normal.
Why is there another Marvel Rivals stream?
I thought you're returning to normal.
What happened?
Guys, it's gonna be just like Apex, where I will check out the new season of a competitive shooter game.
You know how I checked the new season of Overwatch?
I haven't checked Overwatch's new hero.
I don't remember what his name is.
It's been 20 years since we divorced her.
We gotta move on.
Unless they sponsor me, of course.
Unless you sponsor me and I'll be back, baby.
I'll always come back for you, baby.
You were my first love.
You know that, right?
Right, girl?
Anyway, as I was saying, just like Apex, I will be checking out the new seasons of Marvel Rivals, just like I check out every new season of Apex Legends.
And because of that, it's actually crazy.
The new season for Marvel Rivals basically came out with four new characters.
I believe two for now, and then they'll release two more at the half of season one.
Because Mr. Fantastic and Mrs. Fantastic are now available to play.
And then later on, The Thing and... what's his name?
Torch?
Whatever.
I'm sorry.
Chris Evans.
The Human Torch, yes.
The Human Torch will be available on a later date.
For now, we're gonna have two new heroes to try out.
A new map!
And obviously, like, buffs and nerfs and stuff.
We all know who the real star is for the new releases.
Okay, guys?
We all know.
And it's definitely not The Thing.
Oh, and there's a new mode as well.
So yeah, I'm super excited.
I'm really excited to try out the new things for Marvel Rivals.
I might play a little bit of ranked.
I'm not sure yet.
So we'll see how it goes.
I really do want to... I was given an option to try... I told you guys before, but like...
I was given an option to try out these characters in early access, because a lot of streamers were given the option to.
But I decided I really want to try... I figured it's time to, like, you know, take a small little...
So because of that, I decided to try out the new characters live while everyone else gets to as well.
So we'll see.
We'll see how it goes.
I'm super excited.
Also, like, I was very nervous.
I was incredibly nervous about whether or not I made it to top 500 for the season.
And, you know, by the time the stream ended, I checked the leaderboard 30 minutes before.
I was so nervous.
I was like, what if I don't make it?
I didn't play another game, because I was just like... I waited to check the last 30 minutes before the season officially ended.
Oh my god.
All those hours grinding would have been nothing if I...
All those hours.
What if... What if everybody just suddenly climbed 15 points to overtake me?
And thankfully, by the time I checked the 30 minutes before, thankfully, the leaderboards only went up one to two points.
And I was like, oh, thank god.
Thank god all those other players' dreams and...
All those other players' dreams and determinations were crushed that day.
Thank fucking god that they lost hope.
I was like, thank fucking god they all... they didn't make it and their dreams were crushed.
I'm so happy.
So yes, I made it to the leaderboards.
I was top three...
Okay, okay, we gotta wait one more minute.
I was top... oh, I was top 300, I believe, in the end.
So, yay.
At least it wasn't that close.
Thank fucking god.
I was so nervous that's gonna be like...
I was gonna be like, rank 490 or something.
That was what I was really fucking scared about.
Uh, Daniel, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hello Doki, thoughts on Iron Fist and Diamond Plus.
My brother was a GM Iron Fist main, but it's hard to help him climb higher.
Anything helps.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
I avoid every, um... Iron Fist, like...
A really, really good Iron Fist is very scary to play against.
But also, the higher elo you go, the less effective he is.
Because, like, if you're gonna play Iron Fist, you might as well play Black Panther.
Because he's basically the better version of Iron Fist.
And, um... and he... and like... oh yeah, Mr. And like, you would get avoided by every fucking good player because they know how to counter a good Iron Fist.
Oh wait, did Black Panther got nerfed?
I didn't read the patch notes.
Anyway, well, never mind.
Forget what I said.
That's what you should have done last season.
Iron Fist had a high win rate because less people wanted to play Iron Fist.
Because less people played him.
It's a higher win rate if there's a smaller pool of players.
So, never mind.
Black Panther might not... never mind.
You should have listened to this advice like an hour... like, I guess like 5 hours ago.
But, in that case, maybe Iron Fist is now better.
Well, congratulations, you got buffed.
But yes, a really, really good Iron Fist was very scary.
But the higher elo you go, the more people realize.
It took me a while to realize that if an Iron Fist is diving me, that I should not shoot him.
I should not shoot him when he's looking at me.
I should have another player shoot him in the back.
Because the more he blocks, the more HP he gets.
But like, I learned that 3 days ago.
So, it took me 3 days ago to realize that, to figure that out.
But yes, the higher elo you are, the more you realize how dog shit Iron Fist is.
So it is easier to counter when you figure out how he's actually played.
But like, new season, new people.
So, you might succeed this time.
Because all the other characters got nerfed.
All the other melee characters essentially got nerfed.
Alright, let's check it out!
Let's check it out.
The block is 360.
Yeah, but like, it helps a lot.
Because the people in the back can help you more.
Because the front, he's just gonna fucking smash your face in.
But like, the people shooting him, your team can help you burn him, basically, in the end.
Oh, the magic got buffed.
Oh yeah, magic got buffed.
Oh my god, why did they buff magic?
Oh my god.
She's already so scary.
Wait, please check your...
Do I have to reboot the game?
Do I have to restart the game to get in the server?
Oh my god.
Yeah, focus on running.
If you're getting targeted by Iron Fist, you just run and hope your team fucking hears you scream for help.
Oh, no one can get in yet?
Alright, that's good, that's fine, we can still talk.
I'm not trying to avoid you guys, like...
I was just really looking forward to trying out the new season.
Anyway, so I saw...
I like how a lot of people were like...
Doki, when are you gonna...
Doki, when are you gonna buy...
When are you gonna get the new cosmetics?
I refuse to get the new skins until...
I refuse to get the new skins until they sponsor me.
And then I'll...
When you see me buy a cosmetic, it's when you know I finally got sponsored.
I...
I will always be DefaultGrandee until I get sponsored.
And then I'll show my fucking heart out.
I...
I need that bag.
Also, I heard that they made a Bounty Hunter Raccoon skin.
And I'm so sad.
I'm like...
Of course.
One of my most hated characters.
Of course he gets the fucking...
Of course he gets a Bounty Hunter skin.
Of fucking course he does.
That goddamn rodent.
Raccoon hate.
Anyway...
I heard...
The skins are really pretty.
I do have to admit.
But also, they're like...
Of characters that I don't use.
So like, I'm not like...
I'm not like...
No...
I can't...
Because the characters I do use...
I don't really like the skins.
In general.
Like, the Mantis skins and the Luna skins...
Are not like...
I don't like them at all.
Like, I...
I know like, there's the one with the helmet.
But like, her voice distortion...
With the Mantis...
I'm not a fan of her Mantis skin.
Like, I don't...
I don't like the...
The...
The voice distortion.
And just like, how it looks in general.
And I don't like...
It's just my own personal take.
Oh, you're in?
Okay, let me get in.
Um, but...
Oh, okay.
Login traffic is high.
Please wait in queue.
I'm number 174.
Um, and then...
I'm not a fan of the Luna skin.
Because I don't like her...
Costume for it.
I don't like the dress in general.
I just think it's like...
I was like...
Put on some pants.
You're in a war!
Put on some pants!
Yay!
I love her default outfit.
I really like her.
Also, it accentuates her assets more.
That's what I also like about it.
I think the dress covers up too much of like...
What I love about Luna.
Um...
Yay!
See!
That's me!
Yay!
Plat one!
What?
I'm...
It only deranks me to plat one?
Really?
I can literally get to diamond right after?
What?
Okay, that's sweet.
That's cool.
It only deranks me to plat one.
Oh, and I got the golden moon knight skin.
For free.
Let's go.
I heard it deranks you.
Oh my god, yes.
So, I get this.
It tells people that...
It tells people that like...
It's so tiny.
I wish...
Okay, the only thing I really hate about the rewards for top 500...
Is like...
Look how fucking tiny this is.
This is literally...
This is literally the only...
The way people know you got top 500.
It's like in the corner of your banner.
And it's like...
Here it is.
You get like a fucking magnifying glass.
And it's like...
There it is.
There's my top 500.
It's kinda small, but it's there, guys.
Um...
Excuse me, Doki.
That's average size.
I'm sorry, guys.
I'm sorry.
What?
Yeah.
I wish it was...
Better.
I wish they gave us like a little...
The banner thing for it.
Um...
I wish they gave us a banner thing.
Or just some...
Or made it animated.
Or something.
But other than that...
I like that I'm on the leaderboard.
So like...
I was like...
I was there, guys.
I was there.
Okay.
Everybody knows that.
At least I made it to...
Like, it's...
It's just...
Like...
Alright, that's fine.
It's fine.
It's...
I'm okay with that.
I...
I spent two weeks living on Marble Rivals rank for this.
Like, I'm...
It's alright.
I'm okay with that.
I'm okay.
How does it look, though?
What is it like?
Where do I see it?
Um...
How do I...
Oh, yeah.
See the...
Wait.
There's no globe.
Wait up.
Wait.
Where's my name?
Wait a minute.
What do you mean?
Why can't I...
Why can't I look at previous...
Previous seasons?
Wait.
You mean my...
You mean my name already got wiped out?
You trying to tell me that...
It's as if I never existed.
Yeah, but...
I thought...
I thought you could look at previous seasons later, but...
Did season zero ever truly...
I probably got Thanos this game.
I got Thanos stacked away.
It's okay, guys.
It's okay.
Wait, where do I customize?
Guys, no.
It's okay.
But look at this fancy...
Guys, but look.
Guys.
No, but like...
Guys, okay.
Guys, come on.
It's not...
Okay.
Come on, guys.
It's not that bad.
It's...
Okay, guys.
It's not that bad.
Guys, don't.
Guys, come on.
It's...
Guys, guys, guys.
Come on, guys.
It's not that bad.
Guys, it's...
Give me a sec.
It's not that bad, everybody.
Come on.
It's not that bad.
Let me fix this real quick.
It's...
Whoa!
Now, everybody will know.
Oh, my.
I told you, guys.
I told...
It's not...
Look at that.
Now, everyone will know that I'm top 500.
Oh, my God.
It's cold outside, guys.
Leave her alone.
W.
Mercy.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Arcturus, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It's not too late.
You can still escape the rival's black hole.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Look, guys.
See?
I told you.
Oh, my.
It was so worth it.
It was...
Where the...
Where the fuck...
There's no way.
You mean they won't...
What...
What do you mean?
Where's the...
Wait.
Where's the history?
What do you...
Where's the...
Where's the history?
Where is it?
How would...
But, like...
I feel like you should be allowed to see the history.
I...
Okay.
I feel like you should be allowed to see a previous top 500 season.
Dude, relax.
You got the badge.
It's okay.
Maybe they'll add it later.
Okay?
Maybe.
Good news.
You reached...
Oh, nice.
I reached gold 3.
At least gold...
Guys, no.
It's okay.
I...
I believe that...
They will...
They will add the history of previous seasons, guys.
There is...
There's...
There's no...
They have to have added the history.
There's...
There's no way they wouldn't.
Like...
So, like...
It's not like I did all that for nothing.
I believe they're gonna...
There's gonna be, like, you know, the...
My name will be there.
Gamrage, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Where is it?
Alright, let's check out the new support.
Invis...
Oh, wait.
Before...
We should...
We should look at the...
We should look at the character gallery.
It's okay, Toki.
It wasn't your fault.
Wait.
Is it only season 0?
That's not gonna be registered?
Are you...
Do not fucking bait me.
You know I'm, like, easily baitable.
And, like...
You know I'm...
You know I'm weak.
Do not...
No, do not say that.
Do not say that.
Do not tell me that season 1 will count.
But season 0 will...
Do not say that.
Don't say that.
You know I will...
You know I can get...
I'm easily...
I'm weak and will...
And can fold very easily.
Okay, I don't trust you guys.
I'm gonna ask a pro player later.
I don't...
I don't trust you guys.
Season...
There's no way.
It's the first season.
It's...
It exists.
I saw it.
We were all there.
It was not a dream.
Look.
Look at it.
It's real.
Look.
It's right here.
I...
I was...
There's...
There's no way.
I...
I was there though.
I was there.
Alright.
Invisible woman.
She is 4 stars.
Alright.
4 stars.
Okay.
And everybody is like super fucking obsessed over this.
I mean...
Of course.
Also, my favorite part is like people are like...
What the fuck?
Why are they like making skins like this?
But people don't remember that comic book characters back then...
Costumes were like...
Especially for the female heroes...
Were incredibly revealing.
This is them trying to cover it up.
Like the costume that this is based off of...
The original costume that this is based off of...
Was so much worse.
This is...
This was...
This actually...
They actually put more clothes on her.
Versus the original concept.
This is actually a more modest version.
And cooler too.
Honestly, the design is a lot cooler as well.
Like this is a lot cooler.
But yeah.
When they were talking about this...
The issue where this costume came from...
Like...
This part was not covered.
This part was definitely not covered.
Geese, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Season 0, what are you talking about?
The season just started, Doki.
The game just came out, Doki.
What are you talking about?
Thank you for the super chat, Geese.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright.
Oh yeah, and then the...
The emote for just the inner turmoil.
Oh my god.
The only issue I have about...
Miss Fantastic...
Or like, Invisible Woman...
Is the fact that like...
Is that...
She's not...
She doesn't look very special.
Because like...
Her design feels very...
Her default design feels very like...
How do I say it?
Very default.
And it feels very generic.
Yeah, yeah.
Very bland.
Like...
That's why I'm not like a huge fan of it.
Because like...
The only...
It's just...
I know it looks just like her.
It looks just like her.
But her design has never been like super special.
Which like...
I don't know.
That's how I feel.
I feel like her design has never been like...
Super like unique in general.
But it's just been...
Okay.
But like...
What the fuck?
Okay.
Oh my...
Whoa.
Alright.
Sorry.
Launch a force field that can pierce heroes.
Whoa.
Okay.
Flying to maximum...
Alright.
Flying to maximum distance before...
I hope her back is okay.
That's all...
Like...
Oh my god.
My back cracked when I did that.
My...
I was like...
My fucking back...
I hope her back is okay.
That's not comfortable.
That's...
That's not...
It's not even straight at that point.
The back's not even straight at that point.
Alright.
Flying to maximum distance before returning.
Launches a force field that can pierce heroes.
Damaging...
Oh.
Her healing is just...
Her healing is...
Wait.
It's not...
Automatic, right?
Her healing is just Luna.
It's just...
You just gotta aim.
Is it hitscan?
This looks like hitscan.
Okay.
Invisible boundary.
Try to read the text challenge.
Impossible.
Thank you for the super chat, Mike.
Thank you.
Okay.
It's basically like...
Oh, okay.
She's just like Luna.
Okay.
She might be fun to play then.
I don't know if she'll be...
Is it Luna?
Is it like...
Is it hitscan or projectile?
Is it projectile?
God fucking...
Okay.
Before returning...
Alright.
That's a little...
Wait, but what's the point of it returning back?
I don't understand like...
The return...
Oh, does it like ricochet?
So anyone that's in between...
Any...
Oh, it's a boomerang.
So anyone in between it...
Will get...
Oh!
It hits multiple...
Oh, I see.
Okay.
Invisible boundary.
Manifests an unseen force field within a chosen area.
Rendering allies inside undetectable by enemies and providing...
Oh!
Wait.
I could put...
Use this on point.
Oh!
Oh, that's...
Oh.
Wait.
That's so...
That's gonna be so broken if I just...
Put this on the cart.
Especially overtime.
If I use this for overtime...
Oh my god, that's gonna kill everybody.
Yeah.
And then also Star Lord.
I can counter Star Lord.
Yeah.
Invisible...
Yeah, I can like basically like...
Put it on the cart and then like...
Or put it on the point.
And...
It's...
This seems like really good for like...
The point and the cart.
If they shoot, it reveals themselves.
Oh, so like if they start...
Oh, so like if the Star Lord be like...
Legendary!
I'll just be like...
Don't...
Stop shooting!
Everybody!
So...
I just have to yell everybody to be like...
Everyone stop shooting!
When I put it down.
Alright.
Sonic...
Vortex.
Pause!
Stop fighting!
Okay.
So...
Oh, so this is like a mini Groot?
Oh, okay.
So this is like a mini Groot ult.
Basically.
So like a mini...
So it's like a Zarya ult.
But like basically a mini Groot ult.
Oh, she...
Manipulate Sonic...
Oh, her abilities are crazy.
Oh, okay.
So like if I get dived...
Oh, what the fuck?
She counters dive!
No, she has pretty low peel.
No, I can just press E.
I just need to make sure that...
Yeah, I can self-peel.
I can basically boot...
Oh, and I can knock people off.
Oh my gosh, she's like Lucio.
Why would I pull pe...
Oh, I guess I could pull an enemy in front of me if I...
I pull a support in front of me to kill him.
Release a three-hit combo.
The third attack will launch up enemies.
Oh, what?
I have my own melee attack?
My God!
What else does she need?
What the...
Oh my God, what else?
I have more?
Stepping on it propels you...
What the fuck?
Okay.
How much peel do I have?
I'm just gonna leave my other support partner to die at that point.
Like, I'll be like...
Sayonara, I'm fucking gone.
I'm...
My other support's gonna get dived and I'll be like...
Bye.
Okay.
I...
I have a right click?
Okay.
Generate a force shield in front of an ally.
The shield can block damage and provide healing over time.
Enemies that pass through the shield...
Enter invisible state sometime after and grant yourself healing.
I can heal myself?!
Alright, what is the Mr. Fantastic?
To fortify the entire...
This bolster granting damage resistance.
What the fuck?
Okay.
That's...
That's crazy.
Okay.
What is...
Okay, that is the...
Okay, so these are some cooler stuff that I can do.
Oh my God!
The right shift can be spammed?
Wait a minute.
Wait, right shift can be spammed?
Wait.
What was the right...
Oh, I can spam this?
How much do I have from this?
There's no cooldowns!
Wait, what?
Wait!
There's no cooldowns!
Oh, it has a cooldown once it broke.
Oh, thank God.
I was gonna freak out if this doesn't have a...
If it doesn't have a cool...
I would literally freak out if that didn't...
Alright.
Okay, but like...
Other than invisible women...
Okay, Mr. Fantastic though...
Um...
I'm sorry.
He's so...
He's so fucking goofy.
Because like...
Um...
What was it?
When he...
He's so...
He's literally loopy.
Yeah, like...
He's so...
He's...
Oh, my God.
Like...
Look at him.
Oh, my God.
Fantastic!
He looks so funny.
Okay.
Um...
Why play Iron Fist when you could...
Honestly, like...
You know what?
Your friend who's an Iron Fist main...
He's gonna become a Mr. Fantastic main.
Like, look at this.
It's such a terrible...
Oh, my God.
He's so wild.
Look at him.
Oh, my...
He's...
He's built like a fucking tank.
But he's DPS.
What's this?
Gain a shield.
Select a target.
Dealing damage to enemies.
Oh, no.
He's definitely the new Iron Fist.
He...
He's...
He's 100% the new Iron...
What the fuck?
That is loopy.
Wait.
What the fuck?
Reaching full elasticity.
Triggers an inflated state.
That grand shield...
Oh, shit.
What a man.
Okay.
That's...
He's like...
The guy she tells you not to worry about.
What's...
Okay.
So, that's her...
His...
That's his, like, basically team up.
What's the newest team up?
Does anyone know the...
What are the newest team ups this season?
This is still there.
Wait.
It's the same team ups.
They didn't add anything new.
I thought they said...
I thought they were renew...
Oh, wait.
Is this new?
Baltic Union?
No.
They're all the same.
Oh.
No changes.
Oh, it's on season two.
Oh, they're planning on...
Oh, they're changing in season two.
Okay.
I thought...
I thought they were changing it for this season.
But they're changing it for season two.
Okay.
Alright, let's get to know.
Let's get to know.
I will not buy you.
You cannot tempt me.
Also, cause, like...
Also, like...
None of these are characters I actually play.
So, I don't really care that much.
Like...
None of them are, like, characters I care about.
So, I don't really care too much about the...
Also, I found out...
That the team...
The professional team...
That was queue sniping me.
And, like...
That was, like...
That won the tournament.
Their team name...
Was called Mutants.
I deserve it.
Like...
I fucking...
I deserve that.
I...
Their team name was Mutants.
Things make more sense.
Actually, everything makes sense now.
Poor Mutant.
God.
Mutant and proud.
Alright.
I actually want to try out...
Miss Fen...
Uh...
Invisible woman's...
Abilities real quick.
How is the grind?
Surely, we're not off-stream.
Oh, wait.
Is this...
Oh...
They don't know.
I'm not gonna...
I'm not gonna look at what they said.
Alright.
Oh, my God.
Jesus.
My back cracked trying to do this pose.
Alright.
So...
What the fu...
Oh, my God.
I can...
What?
I can be, like...
I can basically...
Give it to different people.
Okay.
And then...
What's the cooldown?
It's five seconds?
Okay.
That...
I feel like that should be longer.
But, like...
That's okay.
That means...
That means I get to play her more.
Oh, my God.
It's five seconds for cooldown when the shield is gone.
And then, this is me being invisible.
And then...
Okay.
If I pierce it, does that mean...
Oh!
What?
Okay.
Alright.
If they all stand in a line...
Oh, my God.
Okay.
How far does it go?
How far does this go, though?
Oh, my God.
Oh, that's...
Wow.
That...
It's basically Moon Knight.
How far does the...
This is the distance.
Oh, my...
Okay.
The distance is far.
So, it's like my clap, but like forever.
Wait, that's actually crazy.
This is like my...
This is better than Luna.
This is actually better than Luna!
Like...
Other...
Okay.
Invisible woman with Luna would go so hard...
With Mantis would go so hard.
Or like her with Luna would go so fucking hard.
Or like...
Oh, my God.
Triple support with invisible woman, Luna, and Mantis.
Nothing will die.
Nothing will fucking die.
The only issue is that it's projectile.
I have to learn how to aim with that.
Yeah, that's the only issue.
Okay.
So, that's the maximum distance here.
Alright.
So, that's the maximum distance.
The only issue is that...
If they're too far, I can't heal them.
I basically can't heal them if they're too far.
So, like, if they're that far...
I can't do anything.
So...
You need somebody close for...
Yeah.
That's still...
That's actually...
She's mid-range healer.
But that's so scary.
If they're all like grouped...
Because, like, you know when you're holding corners and stuff?
When you have to hold a corner...
And then you do that...
That's so scary.
Like...
An invisible woman just heals like this.
All she does is just do that.
And then...
That's so scary.
Like the...
The Wakanda map...
Where we all...
Where the support...
They'll all hold the top right...
The top corner high ground thing.
In the Wakanda map.
With the panther.
I literally could just do that and you're dead.
Like...
What's the distance?
The distance?
I can be here.
That's the distance.
That's how far I can be.
Let's see.
And then...
This one was...
Basically...
Okay, that's eight.
Okay.
This one is the shift.
This one was the pull, right?
I can pull him.
Okay, I can do that.
And I can launch.
Okay.
Yeah, this is the pull.
Okay, the little grab.
Okay, so that's the grab.
And then Q was like...
Don't shoot!
Alright.
Yeah, I can heal and DPS at the same time.
Which is basically like the Luna clap.
Oh my god.
That's crazy.
Okay, I need to like...
I think she'll be meta.
I legitimately think she's gonna be meta.
So I have to learn her.
Alright, let's check out Mr. Fantastic too.
I do think she's gonna be meta.
Big boy!
Hello, lady.
Hello, ladies.
Elf ship.
Yeah, elf ship and walk.
Hello, ladies.
I'm married.
Tap walk.
Oh my god.
Oh, this is basically like new Iron Fist players.
Because I feel like...
Oh my god.
How far?
You see that?
You see that support player over there?
He's gone.
I'm gonna be the...
I'm gonna be the mantis Luna.
I'm gonna be the Luna right there.
And I see Mr. Fantastic just walk by.
And I'll be like...
He's so far.
What's he gonna fucking do?
And Mr. Fantastic is just gonna be like...
He's just gonna be like...
Boom.
And I'll be like...
Please leave me alone.
Alright.
That's crazy.
Can I...
Oh my god.
I hit things if I just do that.
I don't even need to aim.
I can just be like...
Oh my god.
His punches are whip.
Boom.
I can whip him like...
Like that.
Wait.
That's...
That's so scary.
That's actually...
As a support player, I am scared.
I am so scared.
Alright.
Let's try...
Let's try Mr. Fantastic.
Let's try Invisible Woman real quick.
Alright.
Yeah.
They can hit a whole team.
So I'm...
I have fear.
I feel fear.
I feel...
I feel fear right now.
Don't worry.
They'll see my...
They're gonna see my...
That's like...
I see blonde woman.
I see...
I see blonde...
That's what I mean.
She just looks like...
She just looks like Logan Dagger.
So I got confused.
I picked...
I picked a dagger.
I'm wrong.
Blonde woman.
Blonde...
Faithless is just so generic.
Oh my god.
I can't...
I can't take this anymore.
They both look so generic.
I can't.
Oh my god.
I'm so blonde.
They're both blonde.
So I got confused.
I got confused.
Alright.
It's Luffy time.
I already forgot like all his abilities.
So I'm just gonna start punching.
Okay.
Shift is to reflect.
And then...
Oh, E is to grab.
I'm gonna...
I love the icon for it.
It's literally...
Okay, wait.
I'm gonna grab somebody right here.
I'm gonna do it.
Watch this.
Oh my god!
Holy shit.
I wasn't expecting him to fucking grab me though.
Oh my god.
Jesus Christ.
I'm a big boy now.
I'm fucking big.
That's right.
Oh my god.
I'm fucking dead.
Holy shit.
Sorry.
I'm dead now.
I'm dead.
Look.
I...
I can't.
I see those two women and I'm like, who's who?
Alright.
Let's see.
How do I...
Is there a way to walk faster?
No.
Okay.
Alright.
I can also...
Oh, you're...
I...
Yeah, I know.
I can also see.
I just start...
And then I just start punching.
And then...
And then I start...
Why did I grab him?
Oh my god.
What?
How do you...
Okay, that's fine.
I have my wife.
My wife.
That's right.
My wife was here to save me.
That's fucking right.
I don't know what's going on.
I just start punching.
And I just...
Am I reflecting?
Do I reflect any...
Look at me.
That's right.
I'm just gonna...
That's fucking right.
You're not my wife.
You imposter.
There you go.
We're okay.
See, it's that.
I just...
I just ulted.
I just ulted her.
That's fucking right.
Get over here.
Get over.
Oh yeah.
Oh, I reflect nothing.
But that's fine.
I'm just gonna start punching.
So I just started blasting.
Where am I?
Get over here.
What's going on?
Oh shit.
I'm just gonna walk over.
There we go.
Okay, I need to stop going in with that.
And I just start punching.
I'm just...
I'm gonna start punching.
I don't care.
Get over here, Hulk.
I'm the new tank.
I'm the new tank now.
Get over here.
You think just cause you're big...
You think...
That's right.
Get over here.
Shield time.
I'm still gonna start punching.
That's right.
Get over here, Wolverine.
Oh, you're gonna jump away from me?
That's right.
You don't...
Where am I?
Alright, that's easy.
I don't know what happened.
Okay.
I'm done.
Fantastic.
Let's go.
So easy.
She's so strong.
That's right.
My hands are gonna fucking touch you.
Yeah.
I need to stop doing that.
I need to stop just standing there.
And...
I can't help it.
Like, I just wanna walk around like that all the time.
Oh, no.
Wife.
Heal me.
I love you, wife.
Okay.
That's fine.
What's that gonna do?
I got heals.
I got...
Oh, shit.
That's right.
It's so tough.
Oh, no.
He got buffed, too.
Wait.
He got...
He got buffed, too.
I just...
That should be illegal.
Alright.
That's the heal me walk.
Like, it does nothing.
It's just me...
It's just me establishing dominance.
Like, it's actually detrimental for me to do that.
I couldn't help it.
I just need them to know.
It's literally my, like...
It's literally my, like, alpha walk right there.
Alright.
Don't worry.
It's okay.
It's time!
FANTASTIC!
Get over here, fake wife!
I've missed.
Oh, but you think that's fucking right.
Get over here.
Oh, my god.
Oh, no.
It's so goofy.
It's fantastic.
It's okay.
I did my job.
I actually did my job.
I have no goddamn idea what's happening.
I just started punching.
That's really it.
And then I just...
I just started punching.
That is the waddle to escape.
I can't...
I can't help it.
I just...
I just want to establish dominance, you know?
Alright, there you go.
Get over here.
Get...
Oh, no.
He's gonna start smashing.
Oh, yeah!
Ho!
No.
That's fucking right.
Ha-ha!
Not gonna lie, but, like, his, like, voice lines for it is so goofy.
He's like, ha-ha!
Ha-ha!
Alright.
Get over here.
Get...
I'm fucking gonna grab you!
That's right!
Get over here!
You think you can just...
Yeah!
I'm the new tank!
Ha-ha-ha!
Get...
Oh, hello!
You know what it's time to do?
Fantastic!
Okay, that's not fair.
That's actually not fair.
Come on.
No!
Are you serious?!
He's like...
He's so un-serious.
He is.
He's so, like...
He's...
He's so goofy.
He actually is so fucking...
Goofy.
Ha -ha -ha!
I can't take his voice lines seriously because his voice lines are, like...
Like...
You know, I...
You know, I always thought Mr. Re...
Like, you know...
Reed Richards was, like, a cool guy.
I...
He's not.
I don't know.
He's...
He's definitely dad-coded.
He's incredibly dad-coded.
Ha-ha-ha!
He's so...
He's such a goofy-loofy.
Now...
Yeah.
Alright, there you go.
I need the Arshia.
Come on.
Get over here.
Oh!
That's...
Get over here.
Don't worry.
I still have this.
I'm gonna keep grabbing...
Oh, fuck!
Oh!
Reflect!
That's right!
I'm reflecting!
Ha -ha-ha-ha!
What's your arrows gonna do to me?
Ha-ha-ha-ha!
He's such a fucking dad.
Oh, man.
I just...
I just keep shooting.
And I just...
Nice!
Alright.
Oh, yeah!
Oh!
Ha-ha-ha-ha!
Ha -ha-ha-ha!
What's that gonna do, Groot?
What the fuck?
What the fuck is...
Okay, his ult is jack shit.
I'm gonna...
Alright.
I'm not gonna pretend his ult is good.
I'm actually not gonna pretend that his ult is good.
His ult seems pretty bad.
Not gonna lie.
His...
Ha-ha-ha!
His ult seems...
His ult...
His ult seems incredible.
I can't...
We have Ruby.
Oh, I have to like...
Hit multiple targets?
You mean I can't solo ult?
Oh, I won.
Yay!
Oh, it stops if I miss?
Oh!
So it's like again!
Oh, it's basically again!
And again!
Oh!
I didn't realize.
It's like this...
Yeah, I didn't realize it was like again.
You have to keep hitting.
You can.
You just don't miss.
Just don't miss.
It's just that easy.
Okay, Mr. Fantastic is so fucking goofy.
I didn't know what my highlight was during that.
Was it just me just fucking slapping the Wolverine?
As it should.
Oh, it's the again!
Oh my god.
And then that's me killing my fake wife.
Ha -ha-ha-ha!
Alright.
The damage buff number was...
Wait, do I got...
Ha -ha-ha-ha!
Oh my god, wait!
I have 15k damage blocked as a DPS.
Holy shit!
Bro, that's literally...
He's literally a DPS tank.
He has the damage of a...
He has the damage of a DPS but built like a fucking tank.
That's crazy.
That's...
That's actually scary.
That's actually...
That's actually pretty scary.
Not gonna lie.
I am the tank now.
I am the tank.
Alright, now.
Now, it should be guys.
Now, I should be...
No!
Am I...
Am I backfilling?
What's the point?
What's the point of backfilling?
God damn it.
Like...
I can't believe people are willing to take a 15 minute penalty in quick play then fucking playing it out because they can't play.
Like, you're gonna...
You have to take like...
You still have a penalty.
Like, I don't...
Oh shit.
Let me...
Grab this real quick.
Why is there a Loki behind...
Also like, why is there a Loki behind us?
Wait a minute.
Wait!
What the...
Okay, I literally just got here.
I...
Please.
Oh no.
I just got here.
Just...
Yeah, like...
Don't you get a penalty for...
For like, leaving a quick play game?
They'd rather just like, leave a quick play game than fucking...
They'd rather just take the penalty.
Like, that's crazy.
Here we go.
I...
Okay, moon.
It's alright.
I'm okay.
Alright.
Yeah, we can do it.
Yeah.
I assume so.
Wait.
They haven't even fully capped it yet.
It's okay.
We have...
We have Mr. Fantastic.
Alright.
Where are they?
It's fine.
Let me just...
Be over here.
What are they gonna do?
Kill me?
Wow.
Cool skin.
You're so bad.
Oh my god!
Where did he go?
Wait, he shot.
I know I want to be in here.
I...
Oh my god, it was like a magic trick.
It was so scary.
It truly was like a magic trick.
She said disappeared and he disappeared.
What do I do?
Okay.
Nope.
Wait, wait a minute.
Wait a minute.
Welcome to quick play, buddy.
Wait, I can kill this guy too.
Welcome to quick play.
Oh, I can't.
I can't.
Holy...
Play of the game.
Oh my god!
Thank you for the raid!
Thank you, thank you!
Oh, I'll just stay here.
Okay.
Poor Mr. Van.
Oh my god, this is it.
How would they know where I am?
They know.
I forgot I can't shoot.
You're not supposed to shoot, guys.
Okay, I need to leave.
I need to leave.
What are you doing?
What the fuck are you doing?
Oh, wait.
I don't have heals.
They know what they're doing.
Okay, let me just farm this real fast.
And then...
Wait, I hear people behind me.
Oh, you wanna go?
Wait, okay, wait.
Never mind.
I don't wanna go.
Please.
Please, wife.
Alright, you wanna go?
That's fucking right.
Guys.
Guys!
I literally...
I did so much.
Oh no, he's coming over.
Oh no.
Oh no, they're gone.
Where did they go?
Where did they...
Do you think they know?
Oh, they know.
They know.
I'm so slowed.
That's right.
Get over here.
Oh!
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
Um...
They won't chase me, right?
That'd be pretty dumb for them to do.
Okay.
Come on.
Oh no.
Oh, goddammit.
They did the lamp.
The one thing that countered me.
No.
Please.
Please heal me.
He can't aim.
No!
No, where am I?
Where am I?
Okay, we're fine.
Everything is okay.
I'm just gonna kill her.
It's not fine.
I need heals so badly.
Okay.
Okay, come on.
That's not fair.
I literally just got here.
Okay, come on.
Oh, they're just holding hands!
It's not fair!
Like...
Oh, god.
Oh, he's looking at me.
No!
Why, when I play support, my support doesn't hold my hand.
But when...
In quick play, they hold each other's hands.
Why are you holding...
Yes, you don't gain any damage.
Anything from holding hands in quick play!
It's okay.
I'll just farm them from here.
I'm gonna wait until fucking they got tired of invisible women.
I'm just gonna farm.
I'm just gonna frontline here.
And just farm this.
Farm art like this.
Like...
Like, it's just so easy.
You just shoot like that.
Like...
Oh, shit!
Oh, not the moon!
No!
No, please!
I'm just a little guy!
Please!
Okay, the one thing I do miss from Luna is the snowflake.
The snowflake for flankers.
Not the moon.
Don't make me pull out the Punisher!
Cause I will do it if I'm desperate.
I refuse to lose a quick play match.
Jesus Christ.
Reed, go back to your fucking wife!
She's lonely!
That's right.
You can't walk backwards from this!
You can't walk backwards!
Go back to your wife.
She's lonely.
Oh my god.
Am I getting...
Oh, shoot!
That's right.
You can't walk backwards from it.
Alright.
It's fine.
I like Psylocke.
She's actually one of my favorite characters to play in general.
Are they...
What is your plan?
What...
What is...
What was your plan, sir?
What was it?
I can't.
I'm too scared to go in there.
I'm...
Oh my god.
There they are.
The moon!
I'm too scared to go in.
I don't know.
It just seems incredibly dangerous.
Oh.
Get rid of this.
I just...
What?
Oh.
That's why everybody was here.
Okay.
That makes more sense now.
Now I wonder...
I was like, why is everybody there?
Oh.
Because...
Goodbye, wife.
Goodbye, Loki.
Oh, no.
It's him.
It's the smaller Fantastic.
Come on.
I'm gonna beat you up.
Get over here.
Yes.
We did it.
Yay!
So easy.
Man.
What are you gonna do?
Touch the point?
Not Fantastic?
Mr. Fantastic.
Alright.
Now...
Now I should be able to play...
The...
Invisible Woman, right?
Mr. Adequate.
Mr. Average.
Just like my badge.
Just like...
Oh my god.
Just like my badge.
It's okay, guys.
It's okay.
I'm pretty sure they can see it.
I'm...
God, please.
Please.
Alright.
I got the right blonde woman this time.
I got the right one.
It's alright.
Mr. Some part.
Here we go.
It's not small.
It's not...
Guys!
It's not small.
It's...
And it's not...
And it's not the size.
It's how you use it.
And I...
And when...
And I got top 500 using it.
I...
Hey, guys.
Alright.
Let me check out how to play Miss Fantastic.
Because I feel like I would be such a troll if I play her in rank.
I definitely need to figure out how to play her.
Because I feel like she's gonna be...
I don't know.
I feel like she's gonna be meta.
Because her...
I don't know if her heal...
Is her heal output good?
Like Luna?
Oh my god.
My husband.
Hello, husband.
Don't worry.
Haha!
Alright.
I'm gonna see how to play her.
I already forgot her stuff.
What is her...
Her left click is the...
Okay, yeah.
That's what it is.
And I can like...
I basically can just spam this all the time.
And it heals.
Okay.
Yeah, the shield seems like...
The shield seems like it heals a lot in general.
Don't worry.
I'll come back in like...
Wait, what is my E again?
Oh, shit!
That's fucking right.
That's right!
You try to dab me?
Yeah, I need to like figure out how to aim with this.
I need to...
Oh, no.
No!
I got squirreled!
Okay, I need to figure out how to...
I need to figure out this projectile of this.
Because like...
The projectile seems scary.
Like, really difficult to aim.
Yeah.
Oh, did he live?
Oh, no.
Oh, thank god.
The map changed.
I got squirreled.
Oh.
Oh, that's awkward.
That's very awkward.
That's...
Oh, my god.
The map changed!
That's so unlucky.
I got the map.
Don't worry, Raccoon.
I will save us.
Don't worry.
Husband, please!
Mr. Fantastic!
Okay, that pulls people in.
Okay.
Jesus Christ.
Alright.
I need to, like, figure out how to use her shields better, too.
Oh, please.
Oh, my god.
Push him away.
No!
Yeah, her...
Okay.
Her heal output is not...
She's a...
She's a flex support.
Okay, now I realize...
Her...
She has so many buttons.
It, like, gets confusing.
Okay.
I need to realize that, like, her heal output is not as good as I thought it is.
And, like...
Oh, my god.
Her heal output is not that good in general.
I realize.
Wait, I can reflect this.
Okay.
Yeah.
Oh, Captain.
Oh, my god.
Oh, my...
Please!
I can't do anything!
The Captain just dies me!
He's so strong!
Her ult seems good, though.
Her ult seems really good, but, like...
Also, I don't think it's, like, viable...
It's very hard to use her in quick play because people are not stacking up in quick play.
So...
Like, if it was...
If it was, like, not quick play, I think it would be different in general.
I feel.
Just cause, like, I think in quick...
Oh, my god.
I think, like, in ranked, people would be more stacked up to use it viably.
In general.
Oh, my god.
Please.
Where's my Panther?
Stay invisible?
Well, to be invisible, I need to, like, have my...
I should say my jump cooldown.
Yeah.
The more it hits a person, the more damage heal she gives.
Yeah, I just think, like, in quick play, it's definitely harder to utilize her in quick play.
Just cause, like...
Just cause, like, everybody is so spread out.
Everybody's...
People don't play, like, together in quick play a lot.
But, like, especially for cough.
People don't play together in cough, so it's really difficult.
Okay.
I just need to make sure I save my jump for when I get died.
And then save my E for, like...
You save my E for when I get died.
And then also my fist, too.
Okay, I gotta make sure.
And the shift...
Shift, it seems...
Okay, I need to remember the shift and then the shield.
Shield time.
They're so...
Oh, my god.
She has so much kit to her utility.
That, like, it gets so confusing.
I think I can...
I definitely think, like, it's gonna take me a while to learn her.
Because...
She seems, like...
She just seems, like, a lot.
You know?
She definitely...
She is a lot.
There we go.
You know what?
Fuck it.
Disappear!
That's right!
Easy.
Can I get a high ground?
Oh, I can't reach it.
She has a lot of kit.
I'm gonna get, like, super over...
I'm getting, like, super overwhelmed right now.
Playing her.
Because there's just a lot to her.
Her cooldowns, though...
I'd say her cooldowns...
Like, she has...
There's just so much.
Alright.
And I didn't figure out how to aim with her.
In general.
I need to figure out how to aim with this character.
Wait, what?
What the fuck?
Alright.
Because I feel like, aim-wise...
Her projectile is weird.
It's not hitscan.
I'm not very good at...
I'm not very good at projectile.
Yeah, the shield is static, but it's still...
Oh my god.
The shield...
I'm gonna get it back in four seconds, anyway.
The shield is static, but the cooldown is so fast.
And I can just spam it.
Like, I can just do that.
Aim and feet?
Oh no, not the...
Oh no, don't get crushed!
Don't get crushed!
Don't get crushed, guys!
Oh my god, don't worry!
I'm invisible.
Where could I be?
That's fucking right.
That's right, bitch!
Oh, I got...
It's okay.
I...
I sent a message.
Okay?
That's all that matters.
Yeah, the stor...
I heard she got buffed hard.
She got really buffed.
Again!
Okay.
Oh, that's bad.
I should have heals here.
Alright.
It's okay.
You're too far!
You're just a little bit too far!
I...
Like, I...
Like, sometimes I forget I have a shield too.
Oh my god.
Okay.
I don't know if that would do anything.
That's fine.
It's fine.
Wait, I can pull him in!
Watch this!
Okay, I pulled him off.
I pulled him off!
I pulled him away!
Sorry, I'm still...
I'm still figuring out that utility, guys!
Guys, I'm...
I'm still figuring...
Where did he go?
Oh, yes!
But what if I disappear too?
What you gonna do about that?
That's right!
What if I also disappear?
That's fucking right!
Oh shit!
Oh my god!
Oh no, he's coming over!
He's coming over!
I didn't remember left click is pushed away and...
Holy shit!
Guys, I'm scared.
I'm scared.
As a support player, I'm very scared about the Storm Buffs.
I'm...
I'm incredibly scared about the Storm Buffs.
She seems very scary.
I feel like, I feel like I will definitely die a lot of the storm.
Totally figuring out.
I definitely will not be playing her in rank right off the bat.
Because like, she's...
her utility...
Like, I need to fucking always remember to use shield, to use my shield, my shift, and then like this.
Like, it's just so much...
I'm sorry, I say buff her.
She has the lowest pick in rank of all time.
Not all, I'm sorry, not all of all time.
But she's one of the worst characters to play in rank during season zero.
So there was no, so of course they had to buff her.
What I'm very surprised by is why the fuck did they buff Wolverine?
Because now, now I have to worry about, now I have to worry about banning Wolverine and Storm.
Wolverine did not need a buff.
He's already so scary under the right, like, under the right hands, like in high elo.
He's, he's really good in high elo.
God, his like...
That's the only thing I'm like, not like a huge fan of.
And that is like, uh...
Okay, sorry, I need to fucking make sure I don't die.
I don't fucking die.
God, I need to make sure not to shoot my hands.
It's so difficult to not shoot your hands afterwards, because I'm so used to, I'm so used to just keep shooting.
So I need to like, after I jump, I need to just be invisible.
I need to not touch anything after I jump.
I need to like, be like, use my restraint there.
The projectile comes back faster if you aim at the floor.
Yeah, but why, why?
Oh shit, okay.
Sorry, I got healed.
All right, that's fine.
Get in here.
Get in here, fake husband.
Don't worry, I have...
Yeah, I need to remember my shield.
Disappear!
Oh my god, how many?
Okay, I don't have that many.
Okay, I thought I had a lot of discs, but that's fine.
Okay.
Did they, did they buff Thor too, right?
Serious.
They also buffed Thor, so I need to remember that.
Don't worry, it's healing him.
Don't worry.
It's okay.
Please, it's so fine.
Okay, now he's self-healed.
All right.
I'm okay.
Oh wait, did my, did my stream, did my stream die a little bit?
That's weird.
Oh.
My right click.
Cheers!
Holy shit, that's fucking right.
You try to grab me, I'm married.
I'm married.
I'm Mr. Fantastic.
Don't touch me, I have a, I'm Mr. Fantastic.
You know what, I'm gonna grab.
That's not a great idea.
Okay, why did I do that?
Oh my god, why did I do that?
Storm stream, see what he said.
Disappear?
He did it, really?
Oh, that's, that's really funny.
Disappear.
Don't worry.
Oh shit, don't worry, disappear!
Get in here!
Guys, we gotta disappear!
Oh, I don't think we're gonna win.
I don't think, oh.
I don't want to disappear, guys.
I don't, I don't want to disappear.
Uh, super, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Mr. Fantastic is so OP that the stream disappeared the moment she streamed it.
Amazing.
Oh, Mrs. Fantastic, amazing.
Thank you for the super chat, super.
Thank you.
She...
She is...
She is not...
Mrs. Fantastic is not fun to play in quick play.
I'll say it.
I think if I play her in rank, it'd be a lot easier.
In quick play, it's definitely, oh my god, look at everybody playing it.
It's definitely a lot harder to play.
Uh, how are you diamond already?
Jesus Christ, what the fuck, people are diamond already?
I literally, I...
Yeah, um...
In quick play, everybody is like way too spread out for me to actually, uh, do anything in quick play.
So...
Um...
Oh, yeah, they went.
Oh, we had a break.
It's been one hour!
It's...
It's literally, it's been one hour.
How are you guys here already?
I, how are you guys here?
I don't understand.
Okay, I know, like, I had someone I wanted to play rank.
All right, I'm not sure yet.
I'm not sure they are still down because, like, they at, uh, uh...
So, like, I'm not sure yet.
Let me...
I like to keep, like...
Um, oh wait, these are, oh fuck, I forgot rank reset.
So these guys could actually be, I forgot rank reset in itself.
Um...
You know, you want to do rank.
Yeah, I want to do, like, one or two games of rank and then, um...
And then, um, and then call it there.
Because I...
I played a lot of rank already today.
I...
Are you gonna go to Celestio?
Celestio!
I'm going to what?
Okay, wait.
I'm going to eternity.
I don't know about one above all, guys.
I, um...
I...
I don't know about one above all.
We'll, we'll, we'll aim for eternity, guys.
I'm gonna do... Okay, I'm gonna... Oh, wait.
I'm most likely just gonna do what?
Maybe, uh, two games.
All right, I'm gonna do maybe, like, one or two games and then call it there because...
Because we played a lot.
I need you to know... Okay, I'll show you guys how the... Okay, so...
What time did I start?
I started out here.
And then... And then... And then...
Oh, we... And then... And then... And then... We ended here.
At one point, this was hell.
This was actual...
That this was hell, honestly.
This was... This was... This was a lot.
This...
This, this was a lie.
It was, it was, the, the zebra was, I was gonna fucking, oh my god, I was, okay.
I was gonna, oh my, I was gonna fucking, oh.
Alright, alright, whatever.
Alright, alright.
Oh wait, I'm fucking, oh I'm leader.
Alright, let's go.
Let's fucking go.
Okay.
By the way, so we played with Gomez for, uh, for the, uh.
Oh yeah, by the way, he's also a Hololive fan, I found out.
Uh, but we played with Gomez and like the stack he made.
So like, I made a lot of new friends, uh, cause like, I was crashing out hard.
But, but like, apparently, cause he, he's like a fan of GG, uh, from Hololive.
Cause like, when I showed him the, cause the Twitch Rivals team list.
Um, he was like, uh, one person that's in the Twitch Rivals, Marble Rivals, was GG.
But it wasn't the Hololive GG.
It was, um, you know, Pokeloid's girlfriend.
And then, but he like freaked out and was like, oh my god, is that GG from Hololive?
And I was like, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Oh my god.
So, so yeah, I was like, no, no, no, that's, that's a real person.
It's not, it's not the VTuber.
It's, it's the, it's the real person.
So, uh, but yeah, anyway, as I was saying, uh, um, he was part of the problem.
Of why this looks like this.
Why, of why this, of why, of why we, we went from here to, to here.
Anyway,
but here we go.
By the way, during that entire grind, he apparently had one hour of sleep throughout it.
I have no idea how the fuck, how, I have no idea how he's, he's still alive right now.
Wait, is, is the gold not the best one?
Wait, am I supposed to equip the platinum one?
I, I, I actually, I actually don't know.
Wait, is, oh wait, no, gold is, no, he's not top 500.
Oh my god, you're right.
He's not top 500.
That's right, he's not top 500.
So, I get to, I, gold is the best one.
Gold is the best.
Oh my god, everybody here is just the lord.
Oh my god, I'm the best player here and I'm on support.
I, I'm not risking Ms. Fantastic.
I feel like, I don't know, I'm scared.
I feel like I'm gonna throw.
If I try to play Ms. Fantastic, I'm gonna like...
I don't know!
But he's fantastic.
It's the start, you're right, it's the start of the season.
What's the worst that could happen?
You're right, it's plat, I can risk it.
I can risk it in plat.
I'll swap to Luna if I throw.
You're right.
What's the worst that could happen?
I lose?
You're right, start of the season is better to learn this.
Even though everybody technically, everybody technically over here...
Wait!
Holy shit, I told you!
Enraged, this is so OP!
Enraged!
I told you!
It's so OP in rank when everybody is grouped up.
I told you.
This is...
This is so worth it.
This is so worth it in rank.
Oh my god.
Like, they're just all there.
They're just...
They're just all...
Oh my god, they're just all there!
They're just all there.
Like, look at that.
Look at them all just grouped up together.
Look at that.
Oh my god, they're just...
They're just lining up for me like little lemons.
See, it's not a throw.
It's not a throw.
My shield was down.
It's my shield was down.
Look at that.
Like little lemons, they just group up for me.
Oh my god, wait.
I think I can do this.
Okay, that is not what I want to hear.
Who said that?
Our tank.
Okay, that is not what I want to hear from my tank right now.
That's not what I want to hear.
We're fine.
It's okay.
Oh my god.
No.
Oh my god, I tried.
I swear.
It's fine.
Disappear!
I think my teammates right here.
I think that's where they are.
Oh shit.
I think that's where they are, guys.
I think that's where they are.
I need to make sure not to shoot my arms.
I need to make sure...
I can't help it.
Oh no.
That's right.
I'm not invisible.
It's okay.
Okay.
I...
My shield was...
Okay.
The ult...
It has 300 HP, guys.
It's not like...
It's not infinite, guys.
It has...
It has 300 HP.
Like, despite what you want to think.
It's not infinite.
Oh shit, nice.
Alright.
For Wakanda, let's go.
300...
300 plus overtime here.
Like, it can break, guys.
It can actually break, guys.
Okay.
Oh shit!
That's right.
That's fucking right.
I don't know if I'm doing okay.
I legitimately don't know.
I don't know.
I can't tell.
I can't tell right now.
I don't know what I'm doing, too.
Wait, I have Wolverine as ult, right?
I can't disappear.
That's right.
Where am I?
I can't.
I can't do any moves, though.
If I'm disappeared.
Wait, what?
What?
He's so dead.
There's no way he lives.
There's no way.
Oh my god.
I'm okay.
I'm so healthy.
Watch this.
Disappear!
Where am I?
Oh my god.
No.
No, not my ult.
No, not my...
Oh my god.
He took me out of my ult.
That should be illegal.
That's right.
I'll make sure you disappear, alright?
Jesus Christ.
Oh my god.
Please.
Please live.
Everybody.
I realized because we're in plat that nothing...
We can't ban anything.
So, like, that's the one thing I'm very scared about.
We...
We can't...
We can't ban anything right now, so everything is available.
So, like...
Oh, man.
That's so rough.
That's actually gonna be...
Oh, no.
What do I do when they disappear?
What do I do?
Oh, nice.
Nothing.
I don't have to worry.
That's fine.
I forgot the ban stopped existing.
I need to use my E more, too.
I don't use my E at all.
Like, right now.
Alright.
It's technically not a throw yet.
Technically.
Technically, we're not throwing at the moment.
I'm getting...
I'm getting bodied and everything is stuttering.
I'm so sorry.
So, technically, we don't even have a tank right now.
We don't even...
Wait, how are you guys stuttering?
It's fine.
I mean, 12-2.
Wait, we're doing better than our DPS.
That's pretty good.
The only good player...
That's crazy because, like, these are all Eternity players.
I'm pretty sure.
In this elo.
I need to use my...
I need to use my melee, too, more.
Boom, boom, boom, boom, boom.
Yeah, they have to be at least GM to be in my lobby.
Okay, not...
This hurts.
Like...
I don't know.
Is it just me?
Or is this posture?
My back cracked when I did that.
My back actually cracked when I tried to do that posture.
No, I do not have the gamer posture.
What do I do?
I'm gonna break this.
I fucking hate windows.
Where are they gonna go?
Oh, shit.
Are they okay?
I don't...
Okay.
I don't know where to...
Oh my god.
Okay, I guess...
Alright, now it's gone.
Wait, that's up here.
Oh no.
Disappear.
Oh my god.
You don't know.
He doesn't know.
I'm just gonna push shield.
I gave up.
I'm just...
I decided that I'm just gonna use my...
I gave up, guys.
It's okay.
I'm still healing though.
I got the shield up.
Wolverine, live!
Wolverine!
Okay, I need you guys to stand on point though.
Like, I...
I really need you guys.
Okay, but what if I...
What if I...
What if I just do that?
Disappear!
Fight here!
I'm pushing away!
No!
Oh my god, no!
I don't want to disappear!
Oh no.
I know.
Jump, jump, jump, jump, jump.
No!
That was great.
I just pushed them away.
Alright, guys.
I don't think she's good on defense.
Guys.
I...
The almighty push.
Yeah, I think...
She seems like really broken for like overtime pushes.
So I can literally just push her.
Push people off for overtime.
Wait, I can actually like...
I can just push people off.
Wait, that's so scary.
Yeah, I can like push people off during overtime.
I think.
Oh my god.
Goodbye.
I need to heal.
I don't care.
Okay, I care.
I...
I care.
Oh no.
Guys, live.
Live.
I care.
Oh my god.
Live.
Please.
I'll start pushing.
And then I started pushing.
It's okay.
They're all in the line.
It's good.
Stack up.
Please.
Disappear.
Don't let him do anything to you.
Nice.
I don't know.
I think that might have been too...
That ult might have been a little bit too much.
Not gonna lie.
I don't think I needed that ult.
See, go fight.
Line up, everybody.
Hold hands.
I need you all to line up.
Right now.
Okay, if we lose this point, I'm going Luna.
I legitimately don't think this is a...
I don't...
I legitimately think this team needs Nula.
We definitely need Luna here.
Oh no.
Oh no, what do I do?
Where did he go?
Where did he...
Disappear.
What?
Oh my god.
Okay, I thought he was...
Okay, I thought...
Get away.
He's dead, but...
It's the thought that counts, you know?
He still died.
But...
It's the thought that counts.
I did my best.
I actually...
I survived.
As long as I survived.
Oh, I need to be invisible.
One, two...
There we go.
I have self-heal now.
Sorry, I had to heal myself before I cared about you.
I had to...
I need to make sure not to, like, use my...
Okay.
I need to make sure I don't, like...
Disappear!
That's right!
Please, please don't let me...
Please, I need to be inside.
I need to be inside.
Nice.
Easy.
So easy.
Disappear.
I told you, don't fear.
Yeah, but I have a cooldown for it, too.
I have a cooldown for my...
For my jumps.
Yeah, it's more for healing.
I'm not actually healing.
I need a rubber to, like, cancel my shield sometimes, too.
Watch this.
I love just...
Pushing.
That's a cute run.
Get pushed!
That's a fucking run.
Wait, are you okay over there?
Who's in there?
What the fuck is that knockback?
Get pushed.
Get fucking pushed.
Imagine pushing.
That's right.
Fuck you, Munich.
New season.
Save me.
Now, where am I?
What if I just push him?
Oh, fuck!
Oh, shit!
Bitch!
I'm sorry!
Oh my god, I can't push him!
I'm so sorry!
I'm sorry, I didn't mean it.
I didn't mean it.
Karma.
Oh, if I...
Oh, if I shoot the Wahi on myself.
Wait, that's smart.
That's a good tech.
Nice.
Easy.
Easiest game of my life.
Oh my god, it's me!
My first match!
Yay!
I got MVP on my first game!
Alright, my LG.
I'll do one more game.
Yay!
How many times must we teach you, Doki?
Thank you for the super chat.
Super thank you.
Thank you.
Alex, thank you for the super chat.
Get you some oven-baked chicken wings.
Thank you for the super chat, Alex.
I haven't had dinner yet.
Like, I basically just ate some snacks and everything.
And so, like, after this, I'm going to make some Buldak noodles after.
So, I'm super excited.
So, yay!
I'm super excited to make some Buldak noodles after stream.
Alright.
Oh, the queue is taking a while.
I didn't expect it.
Where is everybody?
It's 2 in the morning.
It's prime gamer hours.
How the... wait, is that... that's plat.
Okay.
Is that a plat one?
Oh, my God.
People are like Diamond 3 right now.
That's crazy.
Oh, I'm going to be Diamond...
Wait, if I win my next game, I can be Diamond 3.
Just like all of these guys.
It's prime hours right now, everyone.
It's literally gamer hours.
Oh, my God.
This is it.
We're going to do it.
It has begun.
Alright, this is going to be my LG and then we're going to call it here.
Smitty, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Why do they call an oven when you're in the cold food of hot eat the food?
Huh?
Okay, now I'm just going to...
I'm going to play Luna.
I'm going to play Luna now.
I don't know.
I don't know if like...
If like...
Invisible woman is actually like good.
I can't tell.
I feel like I'm just fucking around on it.
I don't know.
I don't know if she's better than Luna or not.
I feel like Luna's ult is definitely better.
I have no idea.
Wait, it's Dr. Uno?
Oh, yeah.
Yes.
Don't think she can do better, but she...
I'm going to try.
If I win this, I get diamond.
So, I'm fucking trying my fucking heart out.
I want diamond.
Oh my god, Toe Grabber 235.
That's mine.
It's Toe Grabber 235.
No, guys.
No, no, no, no.
We're gonna do this.
This is gonna work.
I'm literally...
I'm literally on...
Or do I put it on Mr. Fantastic?
Cause he's like basically a third tank.
Isn't he?
Isn't he like a third tank?
Alright, here we go.
Oh my god, people in this chat...
Oh my god.
What?
Oh, no.
They have Wolverine.
And we can't ban him.
They have...
Oh, no.
They have Wolverine.
What do we do?
Oh, no.
He's gonna be free.
In flat.
Jesus Christ.
Guys, I don't think I'm winning this.
Guys, I don't think I'm winning.
Very nice.
Magic, magic.
Oh my god.
What do I do?
Okay.
Okay, maybe I...
I don't know.
Maybe I should have played Mr. Fantastic here.
Please.
Please let me through.
Just let us through.
He can't even...
Oh, no.
Okay.
Guys.
Guys, I don't know now.
Guys, if it's...
Guys, this doesn't seem very...
Oh my god.
I'm very worried.
Guys, I don't think I'm winning this.
I...
You know what that means.
It's time.
Guys, you know what that means.
I'm ready to carry this team.
It's not throwing.
It's not...
They're literally...
They're grouped up.
Guys.
I can push him away.
I can't push him away.
I can't...
Guys.
I don't know.
This...
This doesn't look ideal right now.
We need high damage characters.
Okay.
Okay, yeah.
That works.
Oh my god.
It's okay.
I'm Miss Fantastic now.
We got this.
We need a lot of damage.
We got this, guys.
I'm literally...
It's okay.
We got the team up.
We got it.
Okay, guys.
Maybe we don't get diamond.
Wait.
Maybe we can.
No.
We'll get diamond.
We'll end when we get diamond, guys.
We're gonna...
We'll end the stream when we get diamond.
Let's go.
It can't be that bad.
I just need to win one game.
Guys.
I literally just need to win...
I just need to win one...
I need to win one game.
Guys, it's gonna be okay.
I just need to win one game.
Let's go.
Wait, what?
Yeah.
It's just one win.
We're done.
It's alright.
It's fine.
Guys, don't listen to him.
He doesn't know what he's talking about.
Don't worry.
I pushed, but then he walled him off.
It's okay.
He doesn't know what he's talking about.
Don't listen to him.
Guys, don't listen to him.
He's not...
He's a fucking fleshy.
Don't listen to him.
Don't worry.
He's so dead.
He's...
I'm dead!
Am I okay?
It's okay.
It's alright.
We'll be fine.
Don't listen to him.
He doesn't know what the fuck he's talking about.
It's just one win.
Yeah, that's right.
And we can't do anything about it until I'm in diamonds.
I need...
I need to get out of plat, guys.
I can't really walk through.
Guys, I need to get out of plat so I...
Shit.
Oh my god.
Get out!
That's right.
He feels fantastic.
Okay, I don't know what to do here.
Alright.
Disappear!
That's it!
Right here!
They're gonna disappear!
Oh my god.
He doesn't know I'm here, right?
No!
He does!
I got you.
No, I didn't disappear.
I didn't disappear.
I need to get out of plat.
I can't.
I need my bands again, guys.
Get me out of this wild circ...
This wild zoo where everything is playable.
Get me out of here.
Get me out.
Wait a minute.
I need it so that I can have my bands again.
I can't.
I'm not strong enough to go through this wild ride.
Oh, I need...
I should have pulled him.
I need...
What the fuck?!
Is she gonna be okay?
Am I gonna be okay?
Guys, I don't think...
I pushed him.
It's okay, guys.
We lose less in plat.
It's okay.
We lose less in plat, guys.
It's not like the high elos.
Everything will be fine.
It'll all be fine, guys.
Cause I can push him away.
Look at that.
That's when you know I'm a gamer.
That's when you know.
Guys, cause I can just push him away.
Oh, it's alright.
That's fine.
You don't need me right now.
Don't worry.
She won't know that I couldn't kill her.
She won't know that I missed.
It's okay.
I'm literally as MissFantastic just so I can give a team up.
That's okay.
They don't know.
Wait, what's going on?
Oh my...
Get me out of here.
Get me out.
We baited our Magneto.
I'm so sorry.
We baited her.
They don't know.
What's the point?
What's the point of being invisible if she can still see me?
What's the point of being invisible?
Oh my god.
He can see.
You mean he can just see where I am?
Oh wait, I forgot.
I shot my hands.
I keep forgetting if I shoot my hands, they can see where I am.
It's okay.
All we need...
I should've went out of the circle afterwards.
You're right.
I should've went out of the circle.
And...
It's alright.
I gained like how many points?
I gained like a lot, right?
I forgot how much I gained.
I forgot how much I gained for like winning.
33?
Oh, okay.
It's not that bad.
I can get like two.
I just need two wins.
You get 30?
Okay, just two wins, guys.
It's not that bad.
It's just two wins this time.
Just two more.
Two more wins.
It can't be that bad.
It can't be that bad, everyone.
It's just two wins.
Guys, just two wins.
And then I can have hero bands again.
I can...
I can have hero bands.
Look, see?
I'll go Luna.
And then...
And then I won't throw.
I...
How can I possibly throw when I'm on Luna?
How can I...
To be fair, I wasn't even throwing as Mrs. Fantastic.
I was doing so well.
I was doing so fucking well.
Guys...
Just two more wins.
Oh my god, everybody is...
This is the wild west.
I need to get out of that.
I need to get out of this fucking circus.
I need...
They had a Wolverine and we didn't.
We all know...
Honestly, I think Mr. Fantastic is not the best best.
I think if you run...
Depends on the comp, I think.
If you have Mr. Fantastic and Wolverine, that shit seems...
As the DPS, that shit seems really scary.
He seems like a really good dive buster.
Oh, is he?
Okay.
Okay, if he's really good at getting rid of dive, then that's...
Okay, if he's really good at getting rid of dive, that's good.
That's interesting.
Sorry, it's Luna hours.
I need...
I really...
We need a win.
Oh my god, he's over.
He's heading over.
He's heading over, guys.
He's...
Oh no.
I saw Mr. Fantastic.
Mr. Fantastic.
Oh my god.
Guys, I can't believe he picked buff.
Yeah, this character needs a buff.
It's even harder to kill him now.
Oh my god.
He just menacingly walked over.
Why don't they give him another buff?
Oh my god, imagine...
They just make him like...
Yo, what's up with that Hella skin, bro?
Times 10 damage.
You know what?
No, you're right.
He should be even stronger.
Give him a gun.
Give him so that his claw shoots bullets.
Honestly, he's not strong enough.
He should have a gun.
Every time he claws, bullets come out.
Oh my god.
Oh my...
I need a heal.
I need heals.
Luna needs heals.
He even has ult!
What?!
Yo, this character needs a buff.
Make him have...
You're right.
No, he needs to be shorter so he gets hit less.
Oh, you're right.
Yeah, range bullet.
Range Wolverine, where if Wolverine shoots you, you get kidnapped.
He actually has a 45% win rate.
Yeah, he's way too weak.
He should also have passive.
You're so right.
Every time he gets shot, he just gets healed like 50%.
I kind of agree with the buff though.
I mean, I have...
What?
I have passive logic and everything on my side.
Why are they all here?
Oh.
Oh, that would have been a fucking hit right there.
That should have been a fucking hit.
They don't see me.
Oh, when I get hit by...
Wait, mine says all person, mean it.
What is this?
What's going on?
What is he...
They're capping.
Oh, shit.
Yeah, yeah.
Point, point, point.
C9, C9.
I'm gonna die.
Wow.
You guys are super fast.
Oh, man.
Guys.
I thought, you know...
I thought we were gonna do Mantis ult first, guys.
Woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah.
Wait, touch, touch.
I can ult, I can ult, I can ult.
No!
I was gonna ult point!
That's not necessarily respectable, not using support ults to kind of like even the playing field.
Since we have, you know...
I thought Mantis ult was ulting first, so I held mine.
Nah, I'm just fucking with you.
I don't feel...
Now we can have survived with just Mantis ult there.
Cause they had, they had Strangelove.
I just wanna, I'd rather save it for Strangelove.
Oh, my god.
I would've, I'm saving my...
Oh, shit.
Oh, my god.
I hope they're okay.
I don't know.
Oh, my...
Okay, that's fine.
At least I can use it.
Alright.
Alright, I got this, I got this.
Alright, here we go.
They still have Strangelove here.
Oh,
my god.
No!
Oh, shit, I'm fucking dead.
I'm fucking...
Oh, my god.
Oh, I'm okay.
I'm okay.
I'm so safe.
I'm so healthy!
Holy shit!
Anyway, I think they should give Wolverine a gun.
That's really how I feel.
I really think...
Man, if only...
He's a little too weak, guys.
If only he...
He's still going?!
He's still...
Stop!
Oh, my god!
No, fear!
Help!
He's...
Oh, my god!
Why is it still happening?!
I don't know what that is.
How is this still going?
It's like they gave him a gun.
Did he say go forward?
Yeah, I saw.
Oh my god.
Play aggressive here.
I think that's all he's been doing.
What do you mean play aggressive here?
That's all he's been doing this entire time.
That's all he does.
Oh my god, disappear.
Oh no.
I don't know what's going on.
I'm putting on a show.
I'm so scared.
Like, where are we?
Where are we?
Oh my god.
I got scared about the disappear.
Oh, there we go.
There we go.
She was so happy.
Here we go.
Nice.
Why am I playing support when I can do that?
So broken.
They really...
No, no, no.
They nerfed him, guys.
I feel like he could definitely get stronger.
I feel like he could definitely get a lot stronger.
Yeah, yeah.
No, he needed this, guys.
Do you guys think the ban rate on Wolverine is over or under 85%?
It'll probably be above.
Halos is actually...
I think it might be above.
No, 100%.
I feel like they're gonna ban Wolverine.
Like, I think Wolverine is gonna replace the Hawkeye buff.
Definitely.
What?
Oh my god.
How do you...
You don't.
You don't kill him.
He just lives.
I think he...
I think Wolverine replaces...
I think Wolverine replaces Hawkeye, man.
Like, who the fuck needs an arrow when you have a giant Canadian man clawing you?
Oh my god, he's going in.
Oh my god, he's coming in.
Oh my god.
He's going crazy.
He's going fucking crazy.
Oh my god, they went Penny.
They went...
They went Penny.
Oh my god.
They went Penny and...
Holy shit.
And Mr. Fantastic.
But it means nothing.
It means nothing.
Let him have it.
Let him start clawing.
It's a Canadian...
Who is god of hell or a Canadian?
I heard Canadians go, like, the all-in-one team.
Yeah, they just need an Amour.
If they have an Amour, maybe they can stop one Canadian man.
Maybe that's all they need.
One Amour.
Just go full...
Just go full anti-dive.
And then maybe they can stop this Canadian man.
Don't worry.
I will also make sure you live.
I will do it.
You know what?
Go.
Just kill everything.
I have my Amour.
Just...
Just go.
Oh shit.
Okay.
Just walking around with a fucking fat body, bro.
Just seeing his whole team get destroyed.
Oh shit!
Oh nice.
Oh.
That was awkward.
Don't worry.
What is that?
What even was that?
Oh my god.
Somebody stop this spider.
Somebody stop it.
Oh, he knows it's over.
He knows it's over.
It's okay.
We're fine.
We're so fine.
Look at that.
So easy.
It's so cool when what?
When what?
We'll never know.
How is Storm?
She seems really broken.
But like, it doesn't matter because we have Wolverine.
Like, it doesn't matter.
Because we have this...
We have this Canadian.
One more.
Super.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
What's 350 HP buff can do to a Logan?
That and...
That and the snowflake.
The Luna snowflake seems so fucking crate broken with Wolverine.
And all I have to do is just heal the tank and like, my Wolverine just lives forever.
And that's why I need to get out of this.
That is exactly why I need to get out of that.
I need my bans back.
I cannot.
I can't.
Guys, I cannot.
I cannot.
I don't want to be in here any longer.
I need to get out of here.
I need to...
I need to get out of...
I need to get out of here.
Someone free me.
From this...
This personal hell.
Alright, that's fine.
We don't need Logan versus Logan.
I only know this play.
If we win this, we're free.
We'll be freed.
He needs your right.
He needs self heal.
It's not lore accurate, guys.
It's actually crazy to think that Wolverine...
During the first week of season...
First two weeks of season zero...
Everybody thought he was a fucking troll pick.
It's actually crazy that...
And now we all know.
Now...
Now we know.
And then they realize he was busted.
Did they patch out Lunatec?
It doesn't...
Oh, I need to turn off mouse acceleration!
Where is it?
Guys, where's mouse acceleration?
Oh no, I have mouse acceleration on.
Oh!
Oh, it's off by default.
Oh, thank god.
Okay, thank god.
I'm glad it's off by default.
Because I heard...
Remember, that was one of the newer settings.
Wait...
Wait, I think...
Oh my god.
It's okay.
We're fine.
Everything is fine.
Oh, everything might not be fine.
It's fine.
I'll just heal up.
If I heal the Venoms, things will be okay.
Oh, I'm sorry.
I didn't know.
I didn't...
Oh my god!
I forgot how to play with a fucking Venom as a tank!
Because it's...
No, we don't...
Bro, they're running 2-2!
They're running an actual tank lineup?
We're in play, buddy.
We're...
We're in...
We're in play.
Oh my god, he pulled me over.
Fucking freaks.
Okay, this is...
This is rough.
Because...
Oh no.
I think that's where my Venom is.
Guys, I don't know.
This...
This doesn't seem ideal.
I thought they nerfed him.
What is he doing here?
What is he doing?
What is he...
I thought they nerfed this fucker.
What is this Black Panther doing here?
Oh no.
Guys.
I feel like...
I don't know if Venom is...
Is it...
Oh shit, that's...
Okay.
Everything's gonna change now.
Okay, if I die.
I swear to god, if I die.
Okay, it's fine.
What?
Where?
Who?
I...
Please.
Please, I will...
Please, I can't do...
I can't do anything.
Please.
Somebody get this Black Panther...
I'm going lowkey.
I'm fucking gonna go lowkey if I...
I swear to god.
I'm gonna...
Oh...
My god.
I swear to god.
I...
I can't.
Get this guy out of here.
Get this guy out of my lobby.
Get him out of my fucking...
Fucking...
Oh my god.
If you don't kill him.
I swear to god.
Get him out.
Get this fucking guy out.
Oh, he's...
Is he okay?
Oh my god.
Where is he?
Oh, he's okay.
I'm so scared of this Black Panther.
Like...
I thought they nerfed him.
What happened?
Was that all a lie?
That did not feel like a nerf.
Okay.
Um...
I like...
Healed so much.
Like...
You cannot blame me for that.
Is he okay over there?
Oh no.
He's...
Oh my god.
Um...
He's just...
Who would be afraid more?
Wakanda.
Wakanda or a Canadian.
I don't know.
We can make it.
Can we make it?
We can, technically.
Oh no.
I hear him.
We touch.
I'm scared.
I'm so scared.
Hi.
Just let me die.
Just let me fucking die.
I can't.
I...
I can't live.
I'm not going.
I'm not.
I'm going.
I'm not going.
I'm fucking...
I'm going low-key.
I'm going...
I can't.
I cannot.
I cannot play Luna.
It's over.
I cannot.
I cannot play Luna in this.
What do I do?
At least, like, as low-key...
Wait.
Hold on.
As either low-key or...
I feel like I legitimately cannot live.
I cannot live.
But if I have Lamp, maybe?
Maybe?
I don't know.
Oh, wait.
Now I have two tanks.
Do I try again?
Guys...
Okay, I'll try again.
Now that I have two tanks, I'll try again.
But, like, it was not it.
That was absolutely not it.
That was...
I felt like...
I felt like I was left to die so many times.
I just...
It was just like, fuck you in general.
But now that I have two tanks, surely...
Surely things will be different, right?
Surely...
What do you...
Our Mantis was getting fucking...
Oh, let me...
My Mantis fucking died.
Oh my god.
I...
What do you want us to do?
What do you...
Let's go, let's go.
Oh my god.
Bro.
Our Mantis and I...
They don't care about that support.
They're like...
Surely...
Supports are getting trapped and they're like, what?
Don't you...
Look.
Look at us.
Do you really think we want this to happen to us?
Do you...
Please, ult.
Oh my god.
Please, okay.
If you don't want to ult, that's also okay.
I...
That's fine.
It's fine.
Mantis, ult.
Mantis.
Mantis, okay.
Thank you.
Thank you, Mantis for ulting.
I really appreciate it.
I really...
Oh my god, please.
I can't.
Holy shit.
It's okay.
Yasmin, thank you for the 10 gifted subs.
Thank you.
Oh, ships, ships.
Oh my god.
I was on Twitch for so long.
Alright.
I'm coming over.
I'm coming back.
Oh no.
Liv, please.
Please, Liv.
Please.
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
I can just die again.
That's...
Nothing dies.
Nothing fucking dies.
You're doing no damage.
That's fine.
How is this even possible?
But the season just started.
Why are you so angry?
The season...
The season is just...
I'm so angry.
The season started three hours ago.
We're not...
No.
We're alive.
Oh no, he's over there.
He's over...
Oh my god.
Oh my god, he disappeared.
He disappeared.
He's disappeared.
Oh my god.
He disappeared.
I think this is actually a team death.
I...
It's okay, two more games.
That...
That felt like a huge team death right there.
That felt like a huge team death.
I don't know.
I'm not quite sure yet, but...
I felt like...
I felt like that wasn't quite a fair...
Is that what the team felt like last game with my Wolverine?
Is that...
Okay, guys.
Two more games, guys.
Two more games and we'll be free.
Two more...
Two more games, guys.
And then we'll be...
We'll be freed.
This is it.
It'll be fun, I believe.
Two more games.
We can win two in a row.
It can't be that bad.
We can...
Guys, and then like...
And then I'm back to normal.
And then...
I'll be back to normal, everybody.
Surely, right?
Right?
I'll be back to normal after that.
Oh wait, we got a game.
Nice.
I got the bad luck out.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We got the bad luck out of the way.
We have...
Look, see?
We have a fellow Top 500 gamer with me.
Look at that.
See?
He's...
He's there with me right here.
And then, like...
Clearly...
Can't be that all bad.
How can it be that bad?
No Top 500?
Well, I'm not gonna aim for Top 500 in Season 1.
Because now that I know the leaderboards aren't gonna be like...
Public.
There's no point.
Like, actually...
There's like...
There's literally no point.
Because like, I...
I would have been more...
I would have been more motivated if...
If like, you can see the leader...
Yeah, what do I gain from that?
The only reason I wanted Top 500 was so I could brag about being on the leaderboards.
How would you look me up?
How can you look me up, guys?
If I'm not on it?
Where is my clout?
Like...
The website...
Normal people won't look at the website.
Wait, are you...
No way.
Wait, are you trying to say that...
Wait, Season 1?
You guys don't know that.
Season 1 is gonna be registered?
Wait, you guys don't...
Wait.
How do you know?
You could be lying to me right now.
Me?
Yes, you.
I don't know.
Were you in my last game?
What?
Yeah, it was Magneto.
Season 1 leaderboard is still pending?
No, I was Magneto.
You were Wolverine, you dingus.
We looked at the...
Wait, are you serious?
Wait, no.
Don't do this to me.
No, don't do this.
I literally killed Bumble all game.
I never used it besides that moment.
Guys, don't...
Don't do this to me, guys.
Guys, you know I'm easily manipulatable.
It doesn't work.
Guys, don't do this.
You know I...
I...
You know...
You know I can get baited really easily.
You know that.
It's so...
Guys, don't...
Don't do that.
He's like, dude, you guys are not doing any damage.
Like, this is...
This is so embarrassing and like...
I solocapped down his mag three times.
Like, the mag was not doing fuck.
That's a Pharaoh one-trick from fuck Holmes.
That's a Pharaoh one-trick.
That's funny.
That's not right.
Like, mag is right above you, guys.
Wait, there's an Ironman on me.
There's an Ironman on me.
Oh my god.
He just gamma raged me.
Broke their beacon.
Oh, he doesn't get res.
This is...
Do we not look behind?
Do we...
Do we just...
Just like fuck looking behind, I guess?
Like, you know what?
No, fuck you in particular.
You know what?
No, that seems right.
Wait, if there's no bans, then like...
Weren't people just...
I'm scared.
I'm so scared.
I'm so...
Please be anyone buddy else but me.
Please.
Please be anyone else but me.
Please leave him alone.
Please.
What are you?
Please leave me alone.
Is he still behind us?
Is he still...
He's still behind us?
What is he doing?
The Ironman is still just behind us.
Wait, hold on.
Oh, it worked.
It worked.
Ironman's low.
No.
Oh.
Um...
Get over here, everyone.
Let's go.
Let's...
There we go.
This Ironman...
I know that Ironman is still behind us.
But that's okay.
Who cares about what I think, I guess.
Oh, no.
Where is my...
Where is he?
Why is it so loud?
Please.
Please disappear.
Guys, I like how...
I was like, hey guys, what about the Ironman?
And my entire team was like...
What about the Ironman?
What about it?
Just walk forward, Doki.
Just walk forward.
Ironman's still behind us.
Don't shoot.
Oh, no.
I...
We just got fucked.
Why do I still...
Why do I still like this?
Bro, this Ironman is sending a giant signal.
And it's like, I'm behind you.
I think if we lose this fight, you go...
Starlord, I go.
I'm...
I'm behind you.
I have combo, I have combo.
Hit somebody.
Hit anybody.
Oh, my God.
Oh, they're dead.
Please.
Please be...
Oh, the fucker.
Ironman's off left.
Please.
Twitch for...
Twitch for Starlord.
That's like the only value I'm gonna get is comboing with you.
Oh, my God.
Please.
Oh, we...
Somebody get...
Get him away.
Please.
Just kill him.
He's...
He literally is like driving a Ferrari right now.
That's how loud he is.
He's still behind.
That's their left.
Shoot the shield.
Why is nobody looking at him?
What is...
Starlord, Starlord, Starlord.
It's okay, right?
You know what?
We don't need to look at him.
You're right.
We don't...
We don't need to look at him.
You're so right.
Oh, my God.
Where's my team?
Where's...
No.
Oh, my God.
Disappear!
Please.
How does this Ironman...
How is this Ironman getting so much...
No, my mic should be working.
How is he getting...
Oh, my God.
There's an Ironman behind us.
Turning around.
Please.
Oh, my God.
We finally turned around!
We didn't give in!
Guys!
Come on.
Come back.
Oh, no.
Guys, we did it, gamers.
We fucking turned around.
Ironman behind us again.
He's one, he's one.
Oh,
my God.
Hey, guys.
That's alright.
I killed the Ironman.
That's okay.
That's alright.
I did it.
Fuck that one guy.
Oh, shit.
What happened?
We did it, guys!
We turned around!
We did it!
We turned around.
Alright, Mr. Krabs.
Look, I'm gonna say something, but you can't judge me.
Okay.
I actually prefer the mouse itself.
What?
We looked up.
I don't know.
I don't know if Invisible Woman is that good.
Even with the team comp.
I feel like...
I don't know.
I feel like she seems very situational.
Maybe if the team is playing...
If the enemy team is playing very heavy dive, I feel like she's really strong.
I feel like...
I feel like Invisible Woman is really good for, like, heavy dive.
Like, if you're playing against heavy dive comp, because...
Who the fuck plays fucking Freaks?
This freak right here.
I don't like mouse itself.
I think for me, it's because I haven't played with mouse excel in so long.
So, like, I don't like it.
Alright, this is it, guys.
After this, we just need one game.
And I believe...
I believe it'll be fine.
Oh, no.
No, no.
I played Overwatch D.Va and Apex the other day.
Wait, Iron Man behind!
Iron Man behind!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh my god, I hear him.
Iron Man's still on us.
We're 1 for 1.
We're 1 for 1 right now.
2 for 1.
We're down.
Even fight now, Iron Man.
Oh my god.
I bubble you, Gomez.
I need help from... change.
Oh my god, please.
Please, please!
Change, change, change!
We're so healthy!
Okay, not gonna lie...
I feel... hearing that fucking Iron Man...
like, revving up a goddamn Ferrari...
Like...
That shit is so silly.
Like, thank fucking god.
That's right, Tony Stark.
That's fucking right.
You deserve that.
You fucking deserve it, Tony Stark.
Wait, where is he?
Oh my god.
What the fuck is he doing there?
Where is he?
I'm so scared.
Where is the...
Oh no.
Come on, kill her!
Kill her!
Oh!
Oh, but...
It's me!
Oh god.
Where's my team?
Where is he?
Where is the...
Oh, there he is.
Wait, are you okay?
You're so okay.
Okay.
I have to reload.
It's okay.
Oh, it's okay.
Oh my god, I don't feel...
I don't...
I don't feel okay.
Where's the Iron Man?
Where did he go?
Wait, can you heal me?
Heal the Luna?
Yeah.
Okay.
Where is the Iron Man?
I'm so...
Where did he go?
I don't hear the rev.
Oh, there he is.
There he is.
He's revving it up.
He's revving it up right now.
He's driving a car.
Oh no.
There's an Iron Man behind!
Where?
I got pushed into that.
No!
What?
I am ready to put on a show!
Okay, so this is the woman's end.
The old man ends when she dies.
That's...
Okay.
Oh my god!
Dude, how did you guys die to the Iron Man?
I ate that shit.
No, you didn't.
No, the fuck, you didn't.
No, you did not.
No, it hit us.
I watched the...
It just had to go over like slightly.
It must have.
We got him.
No, it did not.
He's like, no, you fucking liar.
You are...
Behind us again?
No,
it did not.
Don't you lie.
We all...
We all saw us get...
Oh, okay.
It's fine.
Okay, I missed.
But he doesn't know that.
He's not...
It's not like he's gonna look at the replay.
Alright, guys.
There's an Iron Man behind us again.
Oh,
please.
Oh, please.
Please look...
Look up!
Do you guys remember how to look up?
What the fuck?
They have a Mr. Fantastic now?
I can bubble you.
If you peek left.
There we go.
Let's go.
Let's put on a show, everybody.
Let's do it.
Iron Man is still behind us.
Haha!
He's dead.
That ult is fucking terrible.
Yeah.
Not gonna lie.
That's a terrible ult.
Even though he did it there.
Haha!
That was late.
What, when he damages it, you three-shot people.
Haha!
Okay.
Oh!
We have our stun, y'all.
I will bubble you when you go for it.
Haha!
Do anything to let me know.
Wait, where's my team?
Where's my team?
Where is he?
I'm gonna back off.
I'm gonna fucking die.
Oh!
Okay.
Alright.
That's fine.
He's just a happy guy.
He's just really happy.
He's just really...
Also, our health is pretty bad.
Not gonna lie.
I don't think he realized how low his nerf is.
Like, what the fuck is he doing?
Haha!
He's like, oh man.
Now that there's no bans.
Now I can play OP characters.
Like...
Hello!
But I don't think he knows it's not as good anymore.
I don't think he knows that.
Oh, there we go.
Now he does.
At least he figured it out.
What the fuck?
He figured it out, guys.
We did it.
He figured it out.
Don't worry, you have...
Oh, no.
I can still live for like one more second.
Are you okay?
I'm not looking backwards.
Disappear!
I don't know.
I don't know what's going on.
Oh my god, I don't know what's going on.
There's a Hulk on me!
Oh my god.
It's okay.
You know what this means!
You know what it means, everyone!
It's time!
Yay!
It's okay.
Get the bubble!
Jeff, no!
What did you do?
Oh my god.
I swear, this has been the first game I've had where I...
This is the first game.
I've never had a game where like...
Iron Man is like...
Iron Man makes the sound of a fucking...
Formula 1 race car.
And we don't do anything about it.
I'm like...
I've never had a...
He's so loud!
How are we letting him do this?
Every other time we were able to shut down...
Like last season zero, we were able to shut down Iron Man.
When he doesn't make a single sound.
But now that he sounds like a fucking goddamn race car.
Everyone's like...
Where is he?
Who made that sound?
Who could it be?
Must have been the wind.
It's like...
And everyone's like...
Where?
He's in the walls.
Oh, blind and deaf.
So loud that everyone...
Yeah, it was so loud that everyone was just deaf at that point.
I think it's a little weird though.
It's a little weird that...
I don't know.
I don't know if he like actually needed that.
Oh my god.
We forgot to avoid him.
We forgot to avoid Broski.
Is that the guy that complained?
Is that the fucking guy that kept bitching?
Is that him?
That was him, right?
Oh my god.
Always so close.
Is that him?
Is that the Pharah one trick that kept bitching?
I'm just scared for it.
Oh no.
They have the Kanthar player?
No.
Please.
Just get me out of the back.
Are you just Kanthar?
Alright.
Go on Namor.
I'm protecting my supports.
Yeah, no.
I'm telling you.
This guy's like the quickest Kanthar I've ever seen.
I'm playing Storm.
I counter him.
How the...
I mean, we beat him last game, but it's just like he's so good at Kanthar.
It's crazy.
I'm scared.
Oh my god.
Get me out of here.
Get me out of...
Get me out of the plant.
I need my bands.
Get me out of plant.
Get me out of...
Get me out of here.
I need my bands.
I can't.
Oh, there he is.
I see him already.
I already see him.
Oh no.
Please.
Kanthar, Kanthar.
I need help, I need help.
Oh my god.
Get me out of here.
Thunder's on us!
Oh my god, please!
What?
What?!
Please!
Get him out of here!
I'm making a comeback.
Oh my god, please.
I need my bands.
I can't.
I'm not strong enough for this.
I am ready to put on a show!
Oh, okay.
We're invisible now.
Alright.
Disappear!
No.
We're gonna disappear.
Oh my god!
Fear Magneto!
Please.
Holy shit.
I...
Oh my god.
Okay, it doesn't matter.
I did the sickest...
Oh my god, it doesn't matter.
It doesn't...
It doesn't fucking...
Oh my god, it doesn't...
It doesn't matter.
I guess I just die.
I...
I guess I just...
I dodged...
I dodged everything, but it doesn't matter.
I...
I even...
I thought he got the Storm of Wood.
I thought he got it.
Oh, there he is.
Someone break his legs, like...
What did they nerf?!
I feel like I got lied to.
I feel like they lied to me.
They said he was nerfed.
It's over.
It was a lie.
That was a fucking lie.
Um...
I'm guessing where they are right now.
Oh my god.
Jesus Christ.
I hope he's okay over there.
I...
There we go, he's fine.
He's fine.
I feel like I got gaslit.
I feel like when people were like...
See, if the guy who was like...
My buddy is an Iron Fist player and like...
I'm wondering like...
What do I play?
It doesn't matter.
He might have got his legs broken.
Like...
I got lied to.
I thought he got...
You know...
Nerfed.
Or whatever.
But clearly...
Clearly, that's a lie.
Even in nerf form, he could do all that.
Like, what...
Like...
That's so fucked.
That's actually so fucked.
Oh my...
Why?
Why did you walk up?
Just...
Just play him.
Just stop playing Iron Fist.
Just play Black Panther at that point.
Just...
Oh my god.
He's so low.
The moon!
Oh no.
She's gonna disappear.
Oh my god.
The moon!
A good Black Panther is so fucking scary.
I just...
I don't know what to do, guys.
What?!
Oh, he's gone!
Oh, thank god!
The evil has been defeated!
Oh my god.
Someone actually broke his knees!
I'm so happy.
Okay.
I...
Like...
I don't know.
What...
I don't know what I can do to save that.
Alright.
I had to use that.
They were...
This is scary because...
They do have strange ult.
So like...
I don't know.
Alright.
That's fine.
We're still healthy.
Our strange is like...
Crazy as fuck.
Not gonna lie.
Our strange is so...
It's actually crazy.
I'm dancing for my fucking life.
Right now.
It's okay.
Oh my...
Okay, that was...
That was so...
Oh my...
Okay.
You know what?
That's fine.
That's...
Just...
That's alright.
You know?
That's okay.
How do we live that?
We don't.
We don't live that.
How do we die to our moon knight?
That's crazy.
What?
A storm?
Just copy me.
No.
Oh, he got it.
He got it.
Disappear!
I can't believe he said...
Copy my storm.
I can't...
I can't believe he said that.
Copy my storm.
And then our Loki was like...
No.
Alright.
This is so winnable.
I believe, guys.
I believe.
We can get out of this.
He was not right.
I don't know.
I don't listen to fair one tricks.
Their opinions are invalid to me.
I'm sorry.
They might as well just not have any opinions.
Fair.
True.
It's true.
Woah!
Are you really sorry?
I'm not.
You're right.
I'm not sorry.
You're on it.
Every fair one trick I've met...
was a fucking asshole.
Like, literally...
The season started three hours ago...
and he was bitching.
I'm like, bro, are you...
Bro, how are you...
How are you this tilted already?
The season started three hours ago...
and your support is getting fucking fucked right now...
by Psylocke and Black Panther...
and you don't look up, turn around.
And he's like, where am I?
And it's like, me and the Mantis looked at each other...
and was like, I don't know, man.
I don't know, man.
Like, we're trying our best to survive right now.
Like, what?
I don't see what is...
Like, how do you die that fast?
I don't understand.
I need to keep...
making sure he's alive.
Jesus Christ.
Our tanks are taking so much damage, though.
It's actually crazy.
Let's go.
Let's fucking go.
How did you die, broski?
Ow!
I am ready to put on a show!
Those portals, man.
What?
Alright, broski was like, don't worry, I got both support odds!
And then he was like, what the fuck do you mean?
The Mantis just ultied.
Nope.
He lied about... What?
How did you...
What?
Did she die in storm all?
Wait, what?
Did he die in storm all?
I literally heard storm all and then she's dead!
I thought you were invincible!
Like, how the fuck do you die?
How do you die in storm all?
Yeah, and then he was like, Loki, copy me.
Yeah, this is exactly... Oh my god, this is exactly why.
Pro bump boots.
I couldn't... I think you gotta nerf that Ankh.
I literally couldn't react.
I couldn't react to the Ankh in time.
I legitimately just couldn't react to, like, destroying the Ankh.
Which is really tilting.
It's really tilting when I can't react to that.
Oh no.
Oh my word.
Where do you think my teammates are?
Let me...
Oh, there you are.
Sorry, I gotta... I had to figure out where it is.
Alright, there you go.
I was like, where are they?
I hope that...
Oh, that's awkward.
That's awkward.
I don't think the...
Guys, I don't think the...
Alright, don't worry.
They'll be fine, right?
Yo, you're so healthy.
You're so healthy, guys.
You guys are all so healthy.
Oh wait, that's insane.
That's insane.
Please, somebody kill... kill these guys.
Nice.
We did it.
Oh, he died mid-cast?
Oh, I was like, there's no way he...
Yeah, no, he definitely died mid-cast.
He got CC'd mid-cast.
Because he got 50% of it back.
Oh my god, we're in Diamond.
I'm finally free.
I can get my bans back.
Oh my god, I get it back.
Yay!
I'm free!
I'm... I'm...
Jeez, I rest now.
How much... wait, how...
How much sleep did you even get?
I'm actually curious.
Oh my god, guys, we did it.
We're... we're... we're out.
We're...
Okay, that's not bad.
He got 4 hours.
He basically slept 5 hours for like...
48 hours.
That's pretty bad.
That's... that's pretty bad.
Hey, guys!
That was really fun!
That's really...
That was really fun.
I had...
I had a great time checking out the new updates.
And... and, like I said...
Emart Rival Streams on... on YouTube will not be very frequent.
I'll mostly be doing it to check out new updates.
So if you want to check out, like, rank grinds and everything...
Please, please, please feel free to follow me on Twitch because I'll mostly do, like, Twitch rank grind if I'm on Twitch.
So, yeah!
Check me out there.
It was really fun checking out the new characters.
I had a fun time looking out... looking at...
Invisible Woman and Mr. Fantastic.
I literally think, like, Invisible Woman is very situational because I feel like Luna Mantis is still just stronger because of Luna.
But Wolverine is definitely busted, like...
Wolverine is...
Wolverine seems really fucked up.
So, I think Hawkeye definitely got mega nerfed.
I think Hawkeye and Hela doesn't seem that strong anymore.
As I was, like, playing against Hawkeye and Hela.
Hey, guys!
I hope you guys had a fun time checking out the new updates with me.
And...
Watching me get back to... at least to Diamond.
As always, everybody...
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get a move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed!
Cause...
You deserve it!
I'm gonna make my bulldog noodles!
For, like...
Lunch, dinner, breakfast today.
I didn't eat lunch.
I ate breakfast today.
But then, like...
I didn't eat lunch or dinner.
Because I went straight to bed.
I was so fucking tired.
You guys don't understand.
I was so tired.
Like, after the rank grind, I just went to bed.
And then, like...
I woke up, streamed.
And then, I went to bed.
And then, I woke up.
Streamed this one.
And now, I guess I eat lunch, dinner, and breakfast.
Cause it's four in the morning.
Alright, guys!
I'll see you guys next time, everybody!
Bye, guys!
Oh, yeah!
For those who don't know my Twitch, I might as well just post my Twitch link.
If you guys want to watch more Marvel...
I don't know when I'll be doing...
I don't know.
Sometimes...
I plan on doing scheduled Twitch streams at least once a week.
Once a week.
So, like, check me out on Twitch if you want to.
Anyway, guys.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody!
Bye, guys!
Bye!